joe biden unleashes an interminable
soporific address to congress and puts
america
completely to sleep while preaching
insane radical leftism
so everything's great i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show ben
shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
you have a right to privacy defend your
rights at expressvpn.com
slash men so that was terrible
i mean legit terrible in every possible
way that was the worst
address to a joint session of congress
i've ever seen i hate these things
generally
you can go back you can listen to my
episodes about addresses to join
sessions of congress
i hate the monarchical aspect of it i
hate the president wandering in
and then everybody cheering yay it's the
president we're so excited and we treat
him like he's a king and then
everybody stands and cheers for
everything he says
the president is a plumber he has a
specific job to do so i hate that from
the beginning but
this was really really bad it was
a barely conscious old daughtered
mumbling at you for an hour and a half
about how he was going to spend more
money than god has ever created
on a variety of proposals that will
completely reshape the nature of
american government
and honest to god i almost wonder
whether the strategy is
he is going to bludgeon you into
unconsciousness
and then while you're unconscious he's
just going to loot your pockets
he's basically cardi b he's going to
bludgeon you into unconsciousness
and then he's just going to rob you
right that's the actual i think premise
of the biden premises
of the biden presidency because here's
the thing the democratic party needs joe
biden they need jobiden specifically
because he is this
because he cannot hold it together
because he starts mumbling
and wandering off into corn fields
because he is not threatening as i have
suggested president house plants is
there to hide the water stain and the
water stain is growing
he's exacerbating the water stain but
they need him there to hide the water
stain because villa kamala harris
co-president harris out there making a
speech about how she was going to spend
10 trillion dollars 10 trillion they
keep saying 6 trillion it's not 6
trillion this is aside from the 4
trillion dollar budget
10 trillion dollars if it were kamala
harris saying this everybody be like wow
that sounds kind of radical but be cool
but because it is this old man they
wheeled in on a gurney who can barely
string together a full paragraph
we're now supposed to believe that it's
all moderate and fine
so i mean maybe the maybe the bug is the
feature
maybe the fact that joe biden is a
horrible speaker maybe the fact that he
is in obvious cognitive decline
maybe the fact that joe biden was almost
inaudible last night
maybe that's the feature and then there
was the optics of the situation so
we're supposed to believe that we're on
this optimistic upswing because you know
what we should be the pandemic is coming
to an
end a huge percentage of americans have
been vaccinated and japan was out there
touting that
but he's in a chamber where people are
socially distanced and masked
every single human in that chamber was
vaccinated
every single one you know would have
been a great message if you actually
want to push vaccinations if you want to
push hope what you would have done
is you would have filled the chamber
with vaccinated people you would have
said all these people are vaccinated
which means
they're back to regular life and you can
be too but joe biden can't say that you
see because if joe biden were to say
that then he wouldn't have any lever
with which to cram into law all of the
spending
joe biden's entire presidency is
premised on the notion that there's a
giant crisis out there and he has a
bunch of manufactured crises like income
inequality or racial inequity
or climate change again some of these
things are real problems
particular particularly climate change
is a problem over the course of the
century but it is a solvable problem
it's an adaptable problem
it is not a crisis he needs an actual
crisis so conveniently for him we just
had
one of the biggest crises in modern
history we had this pandemic but the
problem for him is that the pandemic is
now basically over if you live in a red
state you know the pandemic is over
because everybody is back to normal they
are living their lives so joe biden
has to continue to maintain that the
pandemic is still crippling america
yeah eventually we'll get out of it
somebody's review
eventually well because
he can't acknowledge if it's over now
then we don't need any of his garbage
spending programs that are going to
bankrupt the country
destroy the american dollar raise
inflation kill investment rates
we don't need any of that crap right as
it comes to an end we are going to go
back to the economy we had
just before the pandemic which was the
strongest economy in 50 years by all
available metrics
so you have to prolong the pandemic so
instead you got this bizarre
optics of joe biden vaccinated in a
chamber with 200 other people all
vaccinated
socially distanced and then you'd have a
shot of the crowd and he's supposed to
be exciting us right this is supposed to
be the optimistic wave of the future you
look out
and it looks like what the inside of joe
biden's brain must look like just a
bunch of empty space with an occasional
human here and there
right it's it's it was bizarro world
frankly i don't even know why the
republicans masked
they shouldn't have they should have
gone in there and they should have said
listen you want to take me out of here
i'm vaccinated you're gonna have to
explain to people why i need a mask when
i'm
both vaccinated and socially distanced
the whole idea here from the biden
administration is to continue to promote
coveted panic so they can ram through a
bunch of policy
and they're gonna tell you that their
policy is not radical because this
boring old man is pushing it
because this dude who sounds like your
grandpa not like a grandpa like when he
was in his 60s
and he was fun and you go go-karting
with him but your grandpa when he was in
his 80s and you had to start thinking
about whether you were going to move him
into a nursing home
that guy is going to cram into policy a
bunch of
radical stuff but it's not radical
because of course he speaks like a
german
because how could that guy be
threatening how could that that guy be
radical
so again i think the democratic party
needs him i think they need this
so that was the speech last night and it
was bizarre i mean
he lied over and over and over again he
said a bunch of things that were just
weird
he he cannot sp i can't get over the
fact that there are still people in the
media who are attempting to proclaim
that joe biden is with us
he is not with us he's not been with us
for some time it's very sad he's the
elected president of the united states
it makes me sad for the country that the
is a person
who honest to god cannot get through
a speech in a coherent fashion that was
not coherent last night
i mean here is joe biden just a little
taste here was joe biden
stumbling over himself this is not
because joe biden
had a stammer that he overcame which is
again an act of tremendous strength this
has nothing to do with the stammer
because for most of his career he didn't
speak like this he only speaks like this
now
because he's old and because he's
becoming an adult here is joe biden last
night just
stumbling all over himself with regard
to russia
i know it concerns some of you but i
made very clear to putin
that we're not going to seek excuse me
escalation i said before the speech
that watching biden speak just as an
american is like watching nick willenda
walk over a volcano you just know
there's going to be a point where
there's like
oh man like i hope he's right like
every so often they should cut lives to
him every time he goes up and down the
stairs of air force one because you
could be watching history in the making
okay that's the pitch for joe biden okay
so we're gonna get into the actual
content of the speech in just one moment
because the entire thing here about how
we have to generate enthusiasm for a
president who clearly
not only is someone who we should be
unenthusiastic about but who's promoting
policies
that would make lbj and fdr blush make
barack obama blush for that matter
it's pretty astonishing it really is i
gave a preview last night
on the daily wire backstage what i
thought it was going to sound like and
it was pretty dead-on
it was pretty dead-on so we'll get to
that in just one second first
let us talk about the underwear that
currently grace your took us when you're
wearing tommy tron underwear you're that
much more comfortable you can do
everything better
that's why tommy john doesn't just have
customers they have fanatics it is true
tommy john underwear are fantastic i've
thrown away
all other underwear that i have because
tommy john is just that good they have
hundreds of thousands of fanatics
after 13 years and tens of thousands of
five star reviews call tommy john
the most comfortable underwear ever
because with dozens of comfort
innovations once you've tried tommy john
underwear you're never going back
that lightweight breathable
moisture-wicking fabric four times the
stretch of competing brands
13 million pairs old men across america
love tommy john underwear
if you're not sure what to get for the
moms in your life this mother's day
tommy john's dreamily soft loungewear
is the pampering gift they'll want to
put on the second they unwrap it and
never take it off my wife has tommy
john's stuff too
she loves it as well it really is
fantastic fantastic stuff
right now get 20 off your first order at
tommyjohn.com
ben again that's 20 off your first order
of underwear and loungewear at
tommyjohn.com
that's tommyjohn.com ben c site for
details and get 20
off with your first order at
tommyjohn.com
okay so let's just jump right into joe
biden's speech
so he began last night as you knew he
would with
and everything is hystero historical
behind me stands kamala harris the
president
of the united states who is so
important because she is both very woman
and very black
and that's the important thing here was
joe biden last night doing exactly
i i made fun of him jokingly suggesting
this was how he was going to open and
then he opened that way he's just a
parody of himself
madam vice president no president
has ever said those words from this
podium
no president has ever said those words
and it's about
time
okay then we got to his main pitch so
his main pitch was
everything sucked and then i arrived and
everything was unbelievably great
incredible here i am an old man in a in
a nearly empty chamber with a bunch of
people who are uselessly masked
and yet everything is unbelievably great
he said you know
when i inherited a nation that was
basically done we were toast
and then along came me they wheeled me
in on his
gurney and strapped me propped me up
upright
i stood there and the light it came down
and shine on my bald peach
here he was the president of the united
states
i stand here tonight one day shy
of the hundredth day of my
administration
100 days since i took the oath of office
and lifted my hand
off our family bible and inherited a
nation
we all did that was in crisis the worst
pandemic in a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
now after just 100 days
i can report to the nation america
is on the move again peril in the
possibility
crisis to opportunity setbacks and the
strength
so one thing you're going to notice over
the course of this speech because we're
going to play a lot of it
is how he actively physically declined
in the course of the speech alone
right here he's still awake by the end
he is not by the end he's just
some ambulance he's just sleepwalking
okay so
there are a few things here that are
worthy of note one he just suggested
that january 6 was the worst attack on
our democracy since the civil war
um i have some notes so joe biden has
been alive since the civil war so you
should remember all of these things
how about preventing black people from
doing things like voting
for a century after the civil war
through jim crow laws how about
preventing black people from going to
the same schools as white people
how about you know the internment of the
japanese we could go with
world war one world war ii we could
theoretically go with the cold war we
could go with jen we could go with
september 11th we could go with pearl
harbor
we could go with the assassination of
four separate presidents between the
civil war and now and the shooting of a
fifth president reagan we could go
in fact i can name like many many things
many of things that are worse than
january 6th
in which a bunch of clowns and morons
decided to invade the capital
because they wanted to stop democracy
from moving forward and within an hour
after they were out of the capital
building the entire congress was back in
doing exact see here's the thing about
existential crises to democracy
existential authoritarian
threats they don't end the same day they
are started that is not how things
happen when you have an existential
threat to the democracy
okay so that's just a lie i mean this
january 6th i talked about it i said it
was some of the worst imagery
for the united states politically since
9 11 because to have people ransacking
the capital is really bad
to say that's the worst crisis of
democracy that we've had since the civil
war
is patently crazy it's full on insane
i mean full crazy towns but we're
supposed to just believe this because
again
the contrast that the media and the
biden have created is this narrative
wherein
all was darkness and then the bringer of
light joe
biden 9 000 years old career politician
corrupt as i'll get out congenital liar
this guy he's gonna
and then the light shone down and the
angels descended
if you believe this it's because you're
a sucker it's because you're a sucker
and then joe biden decided you know what
it's time to lie to you so here first of
all it's a giant lie
that we were basically toast on january
when he took office we were toast
we were already starting to tranch out
the vaccines the pandemic was already
starting to end
in economies everywhere we're starting
to get on the move right this was
obviously true but according to joe
biden everything sucked and then he
jumped in front of the parade that was
already moving he started twirling the
baton and dropping it every so often but
it's all him man it was all him
so here was joe biden just lying he i
mean this is just a lie he starts
talking about how
he i made some promissoopi
that to give 100 million shopadoos
in a hundred days okay we were already
giving a million shots a day by the time
joe biden entered office
already giving a million shot today
there is no marked difference
in the trajectory of increase in the
number of shots being given per day
before biden took office and after if
i'm really that great what you would
expect is an exponential trajectory
looks like super slow under trump and
then boom
it pops up under biden now what happened
you have an arithmetic growth you have
just a straight line which means he was
just carrying out plans that were
already left to him
and using a vaccine that was already
left to him but here he is taking credit
for for some reason exceeding the
boundaries of a promise that he made
that we were already meeting it's just
ridiculous here he was
after i promised we'd get 100 million
covet 19 vaccine shots
into people's arms in a hundred days we
will have provided over 220 million
coveted shots
in those hundred days when i was sworn
in on january 20th less than one percent
of the seniors in america are fully
vaccinated against covenant 19.
100 days later 70 percent
of seniors in america over 65 are
protected fully protected
senior deaths from cover 19 are down 80
since january down 80 percent because of
all of you
okay so um quick note there were one
percent of seniors vaccinated
when he took office because we were just
starting to trash out the vaccine
it wasn't because trump was holding back
the vaccine and joe biden suddenly
unleashed it upon an unsuspecting nation
but don't worry the media will go right
along with it don't worry they'll go
right along with this idea that joe
biden has somehow revitalized america
even though he has
done as far as i'm aware precisely
nothing to revitalize america except
scare the living crap out of everybody
who cares about individual rights we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first
you know mother's day is coming up you
know it's a great gift for mom
for your wife for any mother in your
life the pearl source get the highest
quality pearl jewelry up to 70
off retail prices pearl source cuts out
the middleman by eliminating traditional
five times markup by jewelry stores and
selling directly to you
the consumer they have the largest
selection of pearls available anywhere
each jewelry piece is custom made
for you the pearl source offers fast and
free two-day shipping on every order
with zero contact delivery
everything comes beautifully packaged in
an elegant jewelry box it's ready to be
given as a gift comes in the no hassle
60-day money-back guarantee so it is
risk-free
plus with more than 20 years in the
pearl business and nearly 12 000
five-star reviews you can be sure
you are shopping from a trusted retailer
so don't over pay for jewelry go to the
pearl source save up to 70
off of retail prices i love the jewelry
that i've gotten from my wife from the
pearls i know the people who own it
they're super super honorable they are
super honest you're gonna be getting a
great deal and a great piece of jewelry
for a limited time listeners to my show
can take 20
off your entire order for mother's day
go to thepearlsource.com
ben enter promo code bennett check out
for 20 off your entire order
if you want fine pearl jewelry at the
best prices online go straight to the
source the pearl source that's the
pearlsource.com
backslash ben enter promo code ben at
check out the pearlsource.com enter
promo code ben
at checkout and take 20 off your entire
mother's day order they are fantastic
you're really going to
enjoy the gift and so will the mother in
your life okay so
joe biden then continues and he suggests
that the american rescue plan which was
basically just sending people a bunch of
checks
has somehow saved the economy and
created new jobs now here's the thing
the jobs were already being created
because people were going back to work
in fact one of the things the american
rescue plan has done
is tranch out these checks to people
raising
inflation on commodities to an
extraordinary level
and also driven people out of the
workforce because they are making more
money
by taking money from the government at
this point than they are by going back
into the workforce
if you talk to small business owners
everywhere across america they are
trying to hire people
to scale up for the demand and they
can't because people aren't working
when he says the economy created 1.3
million new jobs in 100 days because of
joe biden that's a lie
the economy the government doesn't
create jobs you create jobs
i create jobs i know because we've been
hiring people at daily wire joe biden
didn't create those jobs it's amazing
the same people in the democratic party
elizabeth warren joe biden barack obama
you didn't build that you didn't create
that you know what i'm the one who
signed in the damn paycheck so i'm
pretty sure i did
i'm pretty sure it is not joe biden who
is confiscating my money
and then handing it to people not to
work i'm fairly certain you are not
creating the job sir
here is joe biden claiming credit for an
economic growth bubble that has really
nothing to do with him
and maybe most importantly thanks to the
american rescue plan we're on track
to cut child poverty in america in half
this year and then the process
all this was all going on the economy
created
more than 1 million 300 000 new jobs in
100 days
more jobs in the first hundred days than
any
president on record okay so um just want
to note here
that when he says that he's going to cut
child poverty in america in half this
year
democrats believe that the way that you
cut poverty is just signing people
checks
what they don't understand is that the
way you actually solve poverty is by
incentivizing people to make good solid
decisions that raise them from poverty
permanently
if you just keep signing checks to
people who are in poverty incentivizing
them not to make the decisions that
actually better their lives you're not
curing poverty
if signing checks cured poverty 22
trillion dollars in the war on poverty
would have raised americans
from the from below the poverty line by
percentage the same americans are now
living below the poverty line as we're
living below the poverty line before
the so-called war on poverty in any case
this is all part and parcel
of joe biden's plan to build back buddha
ambadu bananas bedel bell back
the alliteration will save america
here's joe biden talking about building
back better badangu
we have to do more than just build back
better to build back we have to build
back
better we have to compete
more strenuously than we have throughout
our history
we think about it public investment and
infrastructure
has literally transformed america that's
why i propose the american jobs plan
a once-in-a-generation investment in
america itself
this is the largest jobs plan since
world war ii
okay that is not an investment see
investments are where you take a risk
investments are not where i steal your
money and hand it to a third party
that's not an investment that's called
redistribution
when he says that i have a question why
do we need the largest jobs plan since
world war ii we picked up 1.3 million
jobs in the last three months
why do we need it we had record low
unemployment before the pandemic the
pandemics ending people will go back to
work
why do we need your biggest is this
world war ii
was it did i miss the part or were in
the middle of a global world war
involving the draft militarization of
the entire male population of the united
states did i miss that part
because uh i don't see it i don't see it
all this is is just an excuse to
radically expand spending here's the
thing about joe biden's presidency he's
a warrant from president we all know it
over the course of the speech you will
see joe biden decline physically over
the course of just
a speech okay this dude is not serving a
second term he's not running for
reelection he's not serving a second
term so he
dgaf okay at this point he doesn't care
he's going for broke because he has a
very small window
in which to push through all of his
world-beating legislation so that the
history books one day can treat him as a
transformational president
even though he himself declared he was
just going to be a bridge to the next
democrat
and he was going to be a moderate who
restored normalcy but he doesn't
actually want that you see he wants
the the history books to treat him as a
transformational figure
but here's the thing by 2022 he's going
to lose the house
the american people aren't going to like
what he is doing in fact the american
people right now are not particularly
fond of many of his policies
and that's with this enormous bubble
that is being created
this is with the end of the pandemic he
still ain't that popular he's barely
above 50 percent
under normal conditions the dude should
be at 70 percent
somebody's at 50 and that's going to
decline because it's only that ratchet
only works one way for joe biden
so is a very short period of time in
which to cram all this stuff through so
he is going before broke
that is all this is joe biden knows
there will be no second term joe biden
knows in all likelihood he's not going
to have control of congress in two years
and he knows that the pandemic is coming
to an end so he doesn't even have an
excuse for doing all this crap
so it's just you know what i'm going to
push everything i can through
cautions of the wind feminine louise
petals of the metal over that cliff
let's just do
this thing so it's everything it's not
it's not some things but not other
things it's not
a prudent decision-making process about
what to do and what not to do it's do
all the things
at once and dgaf the dgaf
joe biden presidency which is precisely
the opposite of what he campaigned on
he campaigned on restoration of politics
as normal
restoration of bipartisanship
restoration of a certain solidity
and a certain incrementalism in american
governance and then he comes into office
and he's like you know what if i just
spend more money than has ever been
created in the history of mankind or if
i just do that
what if i just completely remake the
relationship between individuals and the
government what if i do that
there's going to be such a backlash to
this and he doesn't even see it i don't
think he even
maybe doesn't care maybe he doesn't care
because he figures he has a short time
window anyway
so you know what if the american people
don't like it tough i'll just run right
over them
because for a for a short time he can
lie to people and people will believe
him
and then as they become dissolution they
won't believe him anymore but it will be
too late because he will already have
shifted the entire nature of the federal
government
okay so it's all the things last night
he didn't just stop there
he continued by suggesting that we don't
just need the american
jobs plan we need a bunch of other stuff
as well
so he says the american jobs plan is
going to is going to put people to work
in america building wind turbines yes
wind turbines will save the american
economy here's joe biden talking about
another green deal new
green new deal debacle for too long
we've failed to use the most
important word when it comes to meeting
the climate crisis
jobs jobs for me
when i think climate change i think jobs
american jobs plan will put engineers
and construction workers to work
building
more energy efficient buildings and
homes
electrical workers ibew members
installing 500 000
charging stations along our highways
there is simply no reason why the blades
for wind turbines can't be built in
pittsburgh instead of beijing
that'll save the country uh no reason
we'll build one's horizons in pittsburgh
okay then he gets into you know what not
just that we gotta pay off all his
cronies
so he says you know who built this
country unions built this country
weird because unionization in the united
states really didn't become a thing
until the early 20th century late 19th
century
so strange because it seems like there's
a lot of the country that was built by
that point but
says joe biden wall street didn't build
this country the middle class built this
country okay
this kind of language is completely
inappropriate for how economics works in
the united states
the united states does not have to find
classes most people in the united states
will occupy
more than one class rung throughout
their life
and most people in the united states
will start off not making a lot of money
when they're 20. and then by the time
they're 30 they'll make more money by
the time they're 40 they'll make even
more money and by the time they retire
they will be up in the middle class or
or upper class
because people make more money over the
course of their lives but the way the
democrats talk about economics is that
you're a middle-class person and you're
stuck in the middle class forever
and you're the person who built the
country because you were once in the
middle class guess what i was once
middle class now i don't earn like a
middle class person
guess what my parents were once middle
class now they're retiring
that is how economics works in the
united states but really all that is
about
is trying to pay off all of his union
cronies so they can then spend a bunch
of money electing democrats because the
most corrupt bargain in american
politics
is that unions all over the country pay
democratic politicians
so that those democratic politicians
give them giveaways it's a
for for a group of people who claim that
they're against corporate cronyism
and against corporations involving
themselves in politics and corruption
and campaign finance reform
the most openly corrupt bargain in
politics is between big labor and the
democratic party here's joe biden
touting it
wall street didn't build this country
the middle class built the country
and unions built the middle class so
that's why i'm calling on congress
to pass protect the right to organize
act the pro act and send it to my desk
so we can support the right to unionize
by the way you know what the pro act
actually does it prevents workers from
having a secret ballot election it
allows the unions to engage what they
call card check
so they can just bully you into voting
for a union that's what he wants
again all of this is not about making
the economy better all of this about
paying off his cronies of course
okay but he's not going to stop there we
need a bunch of other legislation too
he says we need 15 minimum wage and we
need the paycheck
fairness protection act which is
basically just a vehicle for litigation
and he says you know what government can
do all the things the most exciting
thing about joe biden
is he truly believes in his heart that
government can do every single thing on
earth
my favorite he's been saying this for
years but it is it is just a point of
absurdity
he says that the federal government can
end cancer
today presumably so i want to know why
joe biden didn't do it
he's been in the federal government his
entire career does he have the secret
is it dr jill she is the greatest doctor
in america does fauci
have in his safe somewhere the solution
to cancer according to joe biden
we have the he literally said last night
we have the power to end cancer
any time now joe would be fan freaking
tastic
we have the power to end cancer i'm
sorry this is it's such
absurd utopian unicorn fart bull crap
here's we have the power to end cancer
as we know it go for it joe
let's end cancer as we know it it's
within our power
okay let's end cancer it's within our
power
let's let's end cancer and these
bastards over here
they want you to die of cancer because
we could end cancer but they in their
and their budgets and their science and
basic
damage you build better
it's just ridiculous but but again he
has a utopian vision of government
okay but didn't stop there not only does
the federal government have the power
to just you know willy-nilly hire people
not only does the federal government
have the ability to willingly raise
wages and redo work rules not only does
the federal government
have the ability to build back better
they can not only can they on cancer
they also are going to help american
families by wait for it wait for it
they're going to spend a
load of money that's i know you i know
you're shocked
i know that you are just right now you
can't take it that was
you were in suspense what is joe biden
going to do i'm sorry to break it to you
he's going to spend more money
and he's going to spend more money on
stuff that doesn't work so says joe
biden you know how we're going to solve
america's problems
you know we're going to solve america's
unemployment problems the way we're
going to solve america's problems and
our economic problems
is we are going to have the federal
reserve
ex inflate the dollar so that your kid
can go major in lesbian dance theory at
a community college to please dr jill
it's super exciting stuff he said he was
introducing the american family's plan
tonight
we're going to add four years more of
education
because when i look at the k-12 system
in the united states i say wow what a
rousing success has been
when i look at american public schooling
in which we have districts
in which like 10 of kids are graduating
i think you know what you know what
probably the solution to that is more
money into public education
probably what they need is more years of
public health that will totally solve
the problem guys it'll be amazing
and we have to do it for dr jill the
greatest of all doctors
i mean a woman who can diagnose you with
a need for a community college degree
if you have gout it's clip 11 we're
going to add two free years of community
college because dr jill says we should
because she wrote a bad dissertation for
the university of delaware where joe
biden has a building dedicated to his
name
hey here's here's joe biden talking
about why jill
community college professor let's spend
100 billion dollars for jill or
something
when you add two years of free community
college on top of that
you begin to change the dynamic jill is
a community college professor
who teaches today as first lady she's
long said
any country that out educates us is
going to out-compete us
she'll be deeply involved in leading
this effort wow any and
wow any country that out educates is
going to out-compete us so the way that
we're going to educate people is by
pouring more money into failing programs
like head start and we're going to pour
more money into community colleges
which again there's very little evidence
that a community college degree paid for
by the government when you couldn't get
a loan in the first place is going to
radically shift the nature of your
economic trajectory in the united states
but you know it's fine it's all good
because you know what you're saying
now i know i know some of you you
realists in the audience
you you failed the op you're not
optimistic you're too cynical
some of you are saying things like how
could you you know we have to we have to
pay for this
how are we possibly going to pay for
this the good news is joe biden
is going to pay for this the way he's
going to pay for this
is he's going to yell at you about how
rich people are bad he's not actually
going to come up with the money for it
but he's going to tell you rich people
are super bad
he's going to soak the rich that's the
way he's going to pay for all of this
garbage
he says we can do this without
increasing deficits which is just a lie
it is just a
an abject lie the the cbo estimates that
talk about
not increasing deficits assume a 15-year
trailing revenue source on taxation
and an eight-year revenue source and an
eight year revenue suck on on spending
that's not how that crap works okay
anyway here's joe biden saying we can do
this without
increasing deficits i made it clear
we can do without increasing the
deficits let's start
with what i will not do i will not
impose
any tax increase on people making less
than four
hundred thousand dollars it's but it's
time for corporate america
and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share okay now i
understand there are a lot of people who
don't like rich people because they
think they don't quote unquote pay their
fair share
let me explain you're just wrong okay
what do you mean by fair share
the reality is in the united states the
top percent of taxpayers pay all
net taxes all okay when you take
benefits that you get from the
government
against what you give to the government
the top 10 don't receive any benefits
from the government hardly and they pay
a crapload in taxes
the notion that if you're in the middle
class or at the bottom of the economic
spectrum
that you're somehow being jobbed in the
tax system relative to people who are at
the top end of the tax
spectrum it's just insane okay i know
because i've paid
tax having earned income in pretty much
every tax bracket in the united states
and i can tell you
my rate last year in california was well
over 50
in total just income tax it doesn't
include sales tax it doesn't include
property tax
doesn't include any of the ancillary
taxes when he says by the way he's not
going to increase taxes
on people making less than 400 000 a
year this assumes you're a
i don't know maybe it's a safe
assumption i don't know you but it
assumes that you're an idiot
because the reality is dollars are taxed
not people
what does that mean that means that when
a corporation is taxed
you get less income because the
corporation that pays you is now paying
more tax
it means the price is rise you're
getting taxed that way it means that
when he tries to raise the capital gains
tax
that reduces investment in the stock
market which means there's less
investments in the stock market which
means your 401k
goes down this notion that as long as he
is not directly removing an income tax
dollar from you in the middle class it
has no impact on you if he raises taxes
on everything else in the united states
is just absurd that's not how economics
works he knows it he's just lying to you
and then he says i'm not i'm not i'm not
here to i'm not punishing anyone
i'm just i'm just gonna do some class
warfare here i mean this is bernie
sanders stuff
it's amazing so long as he doesn't sound
like this so long as he's not talking
like this
he can just say the exact same thing
while talking like this
here he is talking about how the rich
suck and he's gonna soak him in all this
you know what joe
give up on your houses and then we'll
talk i'm not looking to punish anybody
but i will not add a tax burden
additional tax burden of the middle
class in this country
they're already paying enough i believe
what i propose is fair
fiscally responsible and it raises
revenue to pay for the plans i propose
and will create
millions of jobs that will grow the
economy
and enhance our financial standards he's
losing this game here you can hear it
when you hear someone say they don't
want to raise taxes on the wealthiest
one percent
or corporate america ask them
whose taxes you want to raise instead
who's they going to cut how about we cut
everybody's taxes and we don't raise
everybody's taxes that's my answer i
don't want to raise anybody's taxes i
want to cut everybody's taxes and i want
to spend less
that is the answer now i understand
that's an unpopular answer for some
folks because they want their cake and
they want to eat it too they want to
have lower taxes but also spend more but
that's irresponsible so you know it'd be
responsible cutting spending
that would be the responsible thing and
then joe biden finishes with this little
doozy he says trickle-down economics has
never worked okay trickle-down economics
is a term coined by the left during the
reagan administration
to describe the basic way that
supply-side economics works which
suggests that investment in
entrepreneurship create businesses and
you get paid by those businesses
that is how capitalism works that is how
free markets work
free market economics always works
you know what doesn't work the
government confiscating vast quantities
of wealth
from job creators and companies and then
giving it to people and then assuming
that that's going to create economic
growth
it artificially boosts gdp statistics it
does not create the forward momentum
that an economy requires in order to
create new products and services that
you actually wish to consume
so here he was saying oh trickle down
because he's living in 1983.
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
this time to grow the economy from the
bottom in the middle out
from the bottom and the middle and the
middle out from the bottom
he's starting to slur his words right
you can see the the train is beginning
to slow it is reaching the end of the
line for joe biden
it's time to grow the economy from the
bottom up and the middle out which
ironically is also the title of hunter
biden's autobiography bottom up and
middle out
we'll get to more of joe biden's
incredible state of the union address
in just one second because we didn't get
to the wild part yet guys okay seriously
there's
wild stuff here there's there's bizarre
crap and then they're hills we'll get to
that in one second first
let's talk about the greatest chair of
all time you know you have
a personalized mattress that you sleep
on and you probably have a
nice couch but i'll tell you what you
really need a great office chair i'm
talking about like the best office chart
i have ever sat in the x chair
the x chair has you covered for your
office chair needs the secret is not
only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support which
offers unbelievable lumbar supports your
lower back i get lower back problems and
this chair is great for it
now thanks to their new xhmt technology
you can get heat and massage therapy
while you are sitting at your desk
instead of that old uncomfortable office
chair like what i'm sitting in right now
now you can look forward to spending
hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic massager the xhmt delivers
heat and massage technology right to
your core helping increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy
all perks that make working from home or
the office in absolute joy
we love the x chair right now in our
office the producers have like one x
chair
and basically we have hunger game style
battles to see who gets to sit in the x
chair that day
the x chair is on sale right now for a
hundred dollars off go to
xchairshapiro.com right now that is the
letter x
chair shapiro my name shapiro.com
or call one eight four four four x chair
extra is a 30 day guarantee of complete
comfort you can finance your purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairshapiro.com right now
use code x wheels for free x wheel blade
casters xchairshapiro.com
alrighty we'll get to more joe biden's
bizarre address
last night in just one second first
another high energy episode of candace
is coming at you this friday
this week canada's host political
commentator and interviewer dave rubin
will have a lot to discuss including the
recall election of california governor
gavin newsom
and his new opponent caitlyn jenner
because we live in a in a comic book
reality
subscribe now stream candace live on
fridays 9 pm eastern 8 p.m central only
on daily wear to get 25
off a new membership with code candace
at dailywire.com
subscribe also an added tree for you i
your favorite your favorite
favorite president and favorite
podcasters i also am on candace's show
make sure you grab the audio podcast on
apple spotify wherever your platform of
choice maybe just head over to apple
podcast on spotify and subscribe to
candace today be sure to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so joe biden really did back load a lot
of the wildest stuff in the speech so
all of these spending we're gonna
give you free daycare we're gonna give
you three three and four-year-old head
start programs and free community
college and free this and free that
and a free blueberry for every person
and two belly buttons right
we're gonna do everything you could
possibly that was actually not the wild
part of the speech the wild part of the
speech is when he started talking about
race
and guns and immigration this is where
it got
real weird real fast okay so he started
talking about how america is deeply
racist so he starts off the speech with
america's great uh it's a it's a great
amazing filled with amazing middle class
better back badugu
and and also but you're racist so here
was joe biden saying that you're racist
my fellow americans look we have to come
together
to heal the soul of this nation we've
all seen the name of injustice on the
neck of black americans
now is our opportunity to make some real
progress
the vast majority of men and women
wearing a uniform and a badge serve our
communities and they serve them
honorably
my fellow americans we have to come
together
to rebuild trust between law enforcement
and the people they serve
to root out systemic racism in our
criminal justices okay stop it there we
don't need the rest of this okay so
there
there are a few things that are worthy
of note here one when he says we've seen
the knee of injustice on the neck of
black america this again goes back to
something i've been saying for the last
couple weeks derek chauvin
was convicted of murder and manslaughter
but he was convicted of something of
which he was not even accused
being a racist and america was convicted
on the basis of that of being racist
systemically racist and joe biden just
continues to lie about that that's why
he says things like the knee of
injustice on the neck of black america
because derek chovin
is a stand-in for the racist bigoted
vicious american system also
cops are all wonderful but they're
systemic bigots
right this is this is just bizarre
stupid crap and joe biden pushes it
because
again he needs a crisis in order to
manufacture all the things that he wants
to do
another crisis that allows him to
manufacture this sort of stuff he says
that
gun violence is an epidemic in america
an epidemic
again we just had an epidemic i'm pretty
sure it's not
like a shooting in chicago doesn't make
me pick up my gun and go shoot somebody
that's just ridiculous here he was
doing this routine he says gun violence
is an epidemic in america and then
he starts talking about like deer in
kevlar vests
or or something this is where he starts
just rambling into
into weird territory have you ever seen
a deer or a kevlar fest i saw it one
time
a wolf and wolf wore a
cashmere sweater and it was weird gave
me a hug
i pet him like corn pop's leg and
you don't need a gun here's joe biden
there's no possible justification for
having 100 rounds
in a weapon
what do you think dear wearing kevlar
vests
and kevlar in the jubu um
number one if deer don't wear kevlar
rust but sometimes bad guys do
too does he really think that getting
rid of 100 round
clips is going to somehow or 100 round
magazines is somehow going to lower gun
violence
when was the last time you saw somebody
committed shooting only with that weapon
like seriously how many how many
homicides in america are caused by 100
round magazines
and beyond which forget the magazines
you're just going to have people walking
around with bandoliers right you'll be
like an old western
whatever this is all ridiculous then he
suggested that white supremacy is
terrorism now
this was a departure okay some of this
stuff was ad-libbed and when joe biden
ad-libs you're in wild territory so joe
biden on script is bad enough joe biden
ad-libbing
he's out in space somewhere so he was
talking about the intelligence community
and how white supremacist
terrorism is a threat in the united
states which is true
there are white supremacist terrorists
and they do do violence we have seen
that
but he didn't say white supremacist
terrorism he went off script and he said
something else entirely something that
actually is quite dangerous
okay here's here's what joe biden said
with regard to terrorism
and we won't ignore what our
intelligence agencies have
determined to be the most lethal
terrorist threat to the homeland today
white supremacy is terrorism we're not
going to ignore that either
he didn't say white supremacist to
terrorism we can stop it there okay when
he says white super
it should have been white supremacist
terrorism that's an actual label when he
says white supremacy is terrorism
right there that means something very
different because just think of all the
headlines that you've seen in the past
few months everything is white supremacy
according to the left everything they
don't like is white supremacy
and educational inequality is white
supremacy systemic policing
is white supremacy hand sanitizer is
white supremacy
everything is white so if white
supremacy is terrorism and you're going
to use the power of the federal
government to crack down
on white supremacy and by the transit of
property everything you don't like is
terrorism
this is why you shouldn't let joe biden
off the chain to ad-lib because you end
up
in weird situations okay then he talked
about immigration reform
and this this honestly was one of the
best parts of the speech because he
talked about how politicians have failed
to do immigration reform
well there are tens of thousands of
children being held in being held
in in cages on the border and then he's
like you know my solution to that is he
said this last night his solution to
that
was to pass legislation to make it easy
for the dreamers to stay
create a pathway to citizenship for farm
workers and
put permanent protections on immigrants
for temporary protected status
so in other words we have a crisis on
the border with people washing into the
border
by the tens of thousands and the only
solutions he mentioned last night have
nothing to do with border security
nothing
even border democrats like mark kelly
they're like i didn't hear anything
about the the border there that actually
makes
any sense okay and then joe biden came
to his
long-awaited conclusion this sucker went
on for an hour and a half
and it was like listening to an old
story from your grandparents and they're
starting to doze off and you're starting
to doze off and everybody's starting to
doze off and ted cruz is starting to
doze off
literally okay so he he concludes with
this he suggests
something so absurd and dystopian
that it sort of beggars the imagination
he says that the insurrection was an
existential crisis
for the democracy then he says something
about government and america that is
just
fundamentally untrue the
insurrection was an existential crisis a
test
on whether our democracy could survive
and it did
but the struggle is far from over the
question of whether our democracy
will long endure is both ancient and
urgent
as old as our republic still
vital today our constitution opens with
the words as
trade as it sounds we the people
was time remember that we the people are
the government
you and i not some force in a distant
capital
not some powerful force that we have no
control over it's us
it's we the people this is a fundamental
lie the government is not
us the government is a group of people
elected by us to check and balance each
other and participate in
limited enumerated powers to protect our
individual rights
i am not the government you are not the
government the government is not me
the government is my agent and the
government is supposed to have checks
and balances to prevent it from becoming
simple mob rule when he says the
government is us what he means is there
should be no obstacles to my
utopian and bizarre agenda that's what
he means he means no checks and balances
because after all why are you worried
about government government's you
he means that joe biden is me i'm joe
biden and joe biden is me and therefore
we have a complete confluence of
interest because i don't oppose me
he's a damned liar the fundamental basis
of the constitution of the united states
is that the government is not us which
is why we should worry about what the
government does which is why there
should be enumerated powers which is why
checks and balances
do matter it's why we have federalism
it's why we have
all of these systems that are designed
to prevent the government from invading
individual rights
the government is not us because we are
individuals
but democrats hate individuals they like
the we collectively because the week
collectively allows them to ram down
whatever they damn well please on
individuals
this is joe biden's vision okay this is
radicalism dressed up
in the guise of an old man wandering
around a nursing home
that is joe biden's vision for the
country and he's gonna go
balls out for as long as he is president
of the united states on this thing and
he
he does not care i mean he is willing to
go all the way on this
so i know a lot of people out there like
joe biden's not threatening no he is
deeply threatening
he's deeply threatening specifically
because he plays at being
non-threatening
because he seems non-threatening but
he's actually read that speech that is
the single
most radical address to a joint session
of congress of my lifetime
it makes barack obama seem like a
he wants to spend more money than has
ever been created
completely rewrite the nature of the
relationship between the federal
government and the individual
and he wants to say that he's doing it
in your name because the government is
you
the government is not you joe biden is
not me i don't want joe biden anywhere
near anything that belongs to me
including my individual rights because i
don't trust him with any of those things
and you should not either if you have a
bone of sanity in your body
alrighty so all of that led up to a
response by tim scott so tim scott the
senator from south carolina of course a
a key figure hated by the left because
he happens to be a black republican and
these are folks that
ask candace owens shelby steele asked
thomas soul the most hated people in
america by democrats are black
republicans
according to the democrats they are race
traders which is why you saw by the way
uncle tim
trending last night i'm not kidding you
had white people calling tim scott uncle
tim
after like uncle tom which is just
delightful
you know why they were pissed at tim
scott i kid you not the reason they were
pissed at tim scott
is because tim scott had the temerity to
say america's not racist the leftists
were like
that's a lie america is racist you know
how we know america's racist because
we're racist
there's a certain irony to people
whining that tim scott said that
america's not racist
tim scott should know he's a black man
in america
who's reached wild levels of success
they say
how dare you tim scott say that
america's not racist
yeah uncle tom it's like no you're just
racist
that's all anyway so tim scott gets up
and he gives what was
uh i think a pretty good speech i think
frankly it started off a little slow
and then it really heated up and by the
time he got to the end it was really
really good so he begins it's it's the
only state of the union response address
i've heard that i actually thought
was of benefit to both the republican
party and the person who gave the speech
i've seen a lot of them ranging from
marco rubio in the famous water bottle
thing
to bob mcdonnell the the former governor
of virginia speaking to
a house in like the sort of stilted way
in any case here was
tim scott he says that um basically joe
biden made a promise and now he's
violating his promise which of course is
true
he promised united nation to lower the
temperature
to govern for all americans no matter
how we voted
this was the pitch you just heard it
again but our nation is starving
for more than empty platitudes we need
policies and progress that brings us
closer together but three months in the
actions of the president and his party
are pulling us further and further apart
and of course this is true
and then he continues and he says you
know joe biden wants to define what your
life is going to be like for you but
that's not the way that america is
supposed to work
he says the american dream is about you
defining that for yourself the beauty of
the american dream
is that families get to define it for
themselves
we should be expanding opportunities and
options for all families
not throwing money at certain issues
because democrats think they know best
okay 100 true now here's the part that
really
really pissed off the left is when tim
scott started to talk about race because
black people are not supposed to think
this way according to democrats
democrats are racial essentialists they
believe that black people are all
supposed to vote democrat
because they say that black people have
no agency in america because of white
supremacy
but tim scott says no black people do
have agency because all individuals in
america have agency
and tim scott says a mature adult thing
which is just because you have
experienced racism from individuals
does not implicate the entire system of
the united states which of course is
true
as a jew in the united states i've
experienced some anti-semitism as the
number one target of online
anti-semitism in 2016. that does not
mean that america is systemically
anti-semitic
it's a tim scott makes a rather mature
point here
right so he starts off by saying listen
i've experienced some racism myself
again you're not supposed to say this if
you're tim scott because the immediate
follow-up
for democrats is if you say i've
experienced racism the immediate next
line is supposed to be
because america is racist that's to get
the bizarre spectacle
of lebron james sitting on his billion
dollars while doing propaganda work for
china talking about how america is
deeply racist and terrible to black
people
here's tim scott saying listen i've gone
through some racism myself
it happens to lots of people
i get called uncle tom and the n-word by
progressives
by liberals just last week a national
newspaper suggested my family's poverty
was
actually privileged but says tim scott
and that does not mean that america is
racist
he says the only thing that's racist
right now is the democrats who are
pushing racial essentialism and racial
division
in order to gain what they want
politically a hundred years ago
kids in classrooms were taught the color
of their skin was their most
important characteristic and if they
looked a certain way
they were inferior today cues are being
taught
that the color of their skin defines
them again
and if they look a certain way they're
an oppressor
from colleges to corporations to our
culture people are making money
and gaining power by pretending we
haven't made any progress
at all by doubling down on the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
it's backwards to fight discrimination
with
different types of discrimination and
it's wrong
to try to use our painful past to
dishonestly
shut down debates in the present that's
spectacular stuff
fantastic spectacular stuff there from
senator tim scott and this of course
earned him
the unremitting ire of the media because
how dare he point out the absolute truth
which is that they use charges of
systemic racism in order to cudgel you
into silence in order to shut you up
in order to violate your individual
rights how dare he and tim scott didn't
stop there right he actually explained
how they do this he said you guys you
want to racially polarize us so that you
can use racism
in order to get us to shut up about your
violations of individual rights and
constitutional bargains
he says for example he used hr1 as an
example right this is the federal
the federalizing of basically all state
congressional races and all elections
and hr one is a disaster area it
basically enshrines the possibility of
voter fraud and enshrines ballots to
harvesting
it gets rid of voter security measures
in virtually every state it federalizes
elections
that is a violation of the constitution
because states are supposed to draw up
the way that they do their own elections
that was not given the states never
would have allowed the federal
government to do that ever
okay in the compact that was the
constitution of the united states it
never would have gotten signed
if that had been in the constitution of
the united states it's just blatantly
unconstitutional
but more than that tim scott makes the
point you know you guys are talking
about
the georgia voter law the georgia voter
law is not racist the georgia voter law
is more permissive than for example new
york's voter law but you guys are lying
about that
because the whole point of you
constantly talking about race is that
you can ram through an agenda that
really has nothing to do with race
this is not about civil rights or our
racial past
it's about rigging elections in the
future
and no the same filibuster that
president obama and president biden
praised when they were senators
the same filibuster that the democrats
used to kill my police reform bill last
year
has not suddenly become a racist relic
just because the shoe is now on the
other foot
race is not a political weapon to settle
every
issue the way one side wants it's far
too important okay he is of course
exactly right about this
but the fact that he's exactly right
about this is why the media are so upset
about it so msnbc had a whole panel
where they said they were embarrassed
for tim scott they weren't
embarrassed for the senile old man
warbling out 10 trillion dollars of
spending
to an empty chamber filled with
uselessly masked morons no they weren't
embarrassed for biden they're
embarrassed for tim scott
for saying true things about race
this is msnbc in a nutshell right here
people see him as being
genuine in trying to work on criminal
justice reform
and rather than make even one single
salutatory point on that
he came out and lied about the georgia
bill saying it's easier to vote in
georgia than in new york
i am i am shocked and a bit embarrassed
for him
this was a lost opportunity tim scott
has an
opportunity to make his mark on criminal
justice reform and this ain't gonna do
it
she's unbelievable he tried to pass a
criminal justice reform bill
last year and he was it was filibustered
by the nail vice president of the united
states kamala harris
by the way if anybody ought to be
embarrassed by her by anything it's joy
reid who came out in the last week
last two days and said that she jogs
double masked
outside like an idiot after being
vaccinated
like a pathological lunatic i'm talking
about somebody who's a complete
embarrassment to the public discourse
joy reid
each and every day proves herself an
embarrassment to the public discourse
okay but don't worry the media the same
media who are ripping tim scott up and
down because tim scott's very very bad
they're praising joe biden to the skies
so jonathan capart
told the obviously abject lie
that joe biden his address had the same
energy as other addresses
um which is like saying that a potato
battery
has the same level of energy as a tesla
that's no joe biden was like
if you could have hooked up a heart rate
monitor to joe biden he was barely alive
okay he was nearly flatlined last night
but here's jonathan k part trying to
pump him up
i thought this was despite you know
having maybe a quarter of the people who
are normally there
i agree with lisa it was a much more
intimate speech
but i also think not being in the room
but watching on television
it still for me had the same energy
and i think a little more focused
because we were not distracted
by taunts or booze so much energy so
much brilliance so much wonder and if
you look at the headlines from the media
it's the same
same thing the media are just the
propaganda wing for this party
the actual headline last night is joe
biden proposes more spending that has
ever been proposed by man or god
and old man shouts at moon right that
those were the two headlines
instead here are the headlines from the
washington post which are just
propaganda headlines
biden pictures his ambitious investment
and tax plans as he recasts
the role of government by the way it
took one two three four five six
seven reporters to write that headline
biden pitches his ambitious investment
it's ambitious
and it's an investment you see they use
exactly the same language that he uses
it's not an investment it's not his
money i cannot quote unquote invest
money that i remove from you and just
give to another guy
with no return that's not an investment
okay here's another headline from the
washington post all of this
was on the headline of the washington
post page today
america is on the move again biden seeks
to reassure nation
reeling from a pandemic in remarks to
congress who's reeling
maybe you're reeling i'm not reeling i'm
in florida everything's great we're good
here's the new york times front page
okay this is from their webpage here are
all of the
like here are all the articles you ready
biden makes case
to vastly expand government's role we
have to prove democracy still works he
says
president biden laid out an ambitious
agenda to rewrite the american social
compact by vastly expanding family leave
child care and health care taken
together the collection of initiatives
suggest a breathtaking scope of change
sought by a president who spent a
lifetime as a more conventional lawmaker
the succession of proposals amounts to a
risky gamble
that a country deeply polarized along
ideological lines
is ready for more activist government
and then there's a picture of him being
applauded of course by nancy pelosi and
kamala harris
and then underneath says vice president
kamala harrison speaker nancy pelosi
make history
on deus wow ladies with their ladiness
president biden kicked off his address
with a string of words no american
president has ever said before
madam vice president and madam speaker
okay i have a question define
woman i've been informed that gender is
completely malleable so why do you care
you can't even say that those people are
women if they don't say they're women so
well done media
according to the media tim scott was
terrible last night and joe biden was
magnificent
and then you wonder why trust in the
media is it an all-time low here's the
thing all this is going to come home to
roost
joe biden can be able to pass all of
this stuff because he can't
reconciliation doesn't apply to many of
the things that he's talking about
he's going to try and ram through as
much as he possibly can very very
quickly he's going to overheat the
dollar the dollar is going to inflate
there will be actual cost to you
there will be costs to your business
there will be costs to your life and
then joe biden will
wander off he'll just wander off just
like he
frequently does just kind of like walk
off and he won't know where he is
and then there will be a legacy written
about him by jonathan alter or
by michael buschloss about what a
wonderful president he was and you'll
just be stuck with the bill
so recognize what this was last night it
was an attempt to bludgeon you in
submission
by saying america is bad and also trust
this nice old man to completely change
the nature of government in the united
states don't fall for it
just because the nice old man seems like
a nice old man doesn't mean that what
he's proposing is nice
or decent or good or prosperous for the
united states it's none of those things
already we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon the matt
wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show